prisms okay now prisms are kind of 3d
shape
so we're moving from two dimensions flat
stuff into three dimensions things which
have
like length and breadth and height so
they take up space
okay now prisms are a particular kind of
solid shape that you've learned about
you've been learning about them since
you're seven actually
so let's see if we can draw some and
then come to an explanation of what a
prism is
okay so let me draw one for you
ego
that's a square i'm calling the square
but if i do this
here's my prison to help you see it a
little clearer
because this is um it's it's not
see-through so i'm gonna put some dotted
lines on here all day
so just so you can see the edges of it
that are not on the front of the shape
there you go oh it's so clear now right
okay there you go that's a square prism
that's a square prism
let me draw another one for you i'll
draw it in a different orientation this
time how about
here we go here's a triangle okay
so i'm going to extend it i'm going
downwards this time
here we go there you go
there's another prism and again just to
um make it a little easier to see
oh that should have been further up this
way sorry
that's it i'll put in there's an edge
there
and hmm i think that's all the edges
okay
so here you go here are a couple of
prisms now my question to you is
what makes a prism a prism you could
probably draw a few more in fact we will
draw a few more
well what kind of how can we describe it
yeah michael still have a go
what do you want to go through okay so
firstly the first thing we need to
definitely have is um
it's got to be 3d if it doesn't exist in
three dimensions it definitely cannot be
a prism
okay but there's lots of 3d shapes that
exist
that are prisms right so what's special
about
these guys yes side view is always a
rectangle
whoa okay so let's let's go on um let's
say
side view
okay now this is important this is
important if you have a look on this way
or that way you will see a rectangle
that's important okay
um so from side view you get a rectangle
all the time well
depends like what you mean by side view
right but i mean if you if you come in
and you have a look from this angle
yeah on this you will get a rectangle
and here
if you came and looked on it from that
sort of angle
that way you will see a rectangle
anything else
anything else those edges
um there are lots of edges there are
lots of edges
and actually that's kind of important
there there can't be any curvy bits
yes a cylinder is a cylinder not a prism
which is interesting it's kind of very
very close
uh i suppose we should take lots of
straight edges straight
top um so if it's like a triangle
there'll be like two triangles
say that again say it again slowly
so this this guy here which is a
triangular prism what about it there
will be two triangles
in there ah okay now
this is this is starting to get at the
important idea this is a triangular
prism i said before this is a square
prism
right with the triangular prism let me
see if i get this right tom said
rightly there are two triangles you can
see them there
right uh here's one of them at the top
there's one okay and where's the other
one
it's on if this is the top and that's
the bottom isn't it so there you go
there's another triangle okay now i'm
going to go after this because i think
this is the key
okay in fact i think there is more than
just two triangles here
i think there's a whole bunch of them if
you cut across this shape
you'll get a whole bunch of triangles
you make lots and lots of triangles if
you can imagine it kind of like a um
if this was a triangular prism load of
bread
and you cut into slices every slice will
be the same shape as those two triangles
that tom picked out
right now those instead of slices okay
we have a more
specific phrase for that which is
you're cutting across okay you're
cutting across so we call
it a cross section
okay a cross section so the this is and
this is really the most important thing
about the prism
okay the cross sections are all the same
shape in the case we just talked about
they're all the same triangle
over and over and over and over again
okay and they have to be polygons
so that's why we were saying before the
cylinder
is not a prism because if you cut it
across into each slices
the slices are not polygons are they
what are they
okay um if you slice a cylinder you'll
get circles
now by the way that shouldn't be
surprising because
the um the word prism
is actually um it's from a latin word
foresaw
get that prism means
to soar
that's what the word actually means okay
and the idea is that you can take these
kinds of shapes
and you can saw them across and you'll
get the same kind of
cross-section okay does that make sense